[Music]
hey what's up
i am wearing my nasa headset because we
are launching rocket chips today
not really i take a protein powder and i
just found out
dr josh axe the creator lives here in
nashville i had him on the show to talk
nutrition and mental health and
relationships
stay tuned
[Music]
hey what up what up this is john and
welcome to the dr john delony's show
where we talk about your life your
friends your parents your relationships
we talk about
you so glad that you're here got a
special
special interview episode today so
we talked about this um i'm a nerd about
what goes in my body
unless i get off the rails with my gummy
candies and
breads and pastas and those things chips
in case so if it's not that stuff i'm
really
particular about what i eat and i've the
last i don't know 10 15 years i've
become obsessive about trying to find
the right protein powders and collagen
and bone broth and blah blah blah
so i come to find out that the guy who
makes
the stuff that i take the protein
powders and the
partridge in a pear tree he lives here
in town his name's
dr joshua axe and he owns ancient
nutrition
and he's kind of a controversial figure
out there
and i i wanted to meet him and one of
the ways i like to meet people just say
hey you want to be on my show and so he
came on the show
we had a we have a great conversation
about
um he's a guy who's uh he's a christian
guy
he's uh leads his business with faith
principles
um he has got a little kid he's married
talks a lot about what he does why he
does it
and then talks about how he deals with
the criticism
and the challenges and the relationship
issues that go on behind
running a company so it's an interesting
fun conversation i know you're going to
like it i know you're going to say no
oh no i don't agree with that and i know
that the youtubes and the internets and
the podcasts
all the comments are going to be awesome
great
bring them on we're so excited that you
get to sit in on a conversation between
me
and a new guy just met who i really like
his name is dr joshua axe
stay tuned
hey so it's good to talk to you dr axe
thanks for joining us hey thanks for
having me john so listen
when i i moved to nashville about three
years ago
i've been using your protein and
collagen bone broth
i've been using these products for a
while i've always been the weird fringe
kid around
all my buddies and um then when i got to
nashville and i came over here to
ramsey solutions i didn't realize that
you lived in town and so then i thought
man let's get this guy on the show
just because i i use your stuff and i
want other people to hear about it and i
think that's
i think it's rad to connect with human
beings behind the fancy products and all
that man
well you know i've been nashville about
13 years now and i've been a huge fan of
everything
yeah you know dave ramsey's done for a
long time followed the organization been
so inspired by just uh you know the
transformation that
uh i know that your organization here
has helped so many people with so
anyways
i'm yeah i'm honored to be on the show
that's awesome man okay so
the the people who watch and listen to
this will know i like to talk about the
stuff but i like to talk about the
people behind the stuff too
and so let's talk about this tell me
about the um
take a few minutes tell me about the you
got multiple companies you got multiple
products like
what who are you and what are you doing
sure well for me you know i uh
my my journey really started with a
health crisis in my family so my mom
growing up was diagnosed with cancer
and my mom looked very healthy and
that's really what drove me to want to
become a physician is i saw my mom
live in that conventional medical system
she had chemotherapy
she had a mastectomy and i remember
thinking of myself as a kid
i never want to see anyone have to go
through this sort of pain again
and so i started studying nutrition in
fact at 14 years old john i said to
myself
i don't know anything about nutrition
but i do know this one thing i know that
soda is bad so literally 14 years old i
stopped drinking soda
and then you know i said hey i want to
keep learning about this stuff started
studying nutrition
and then went on to school was about to
move to nashville and open a functional
medicine clinic and i got a call from my
mom and she said
i've just been diagnosed again with
serious illness
and so we just transformed everything i
learned i started applying everything i
used to her we started
number one we started with prayer and
along with that she started using
essential oils we started using
um you know ju lots of vegetables
juicing vegetables eating a lot of what
we call super foods taking herbs like
turmeric
and she recovered completely and
naturally
using what i used as i always say food
is medicine and then i've
opened up my functional medicine
practice in nashville which i don't
operate anymore but i did for about five
or five to six years
and in that clinic i really wanted to
help see families transform their health
and i really think it really starts with
the family
so i focused on these families and then
and then from there that birth draxe.com
which
was an educational platform to help
educate people on how to use food as
medicine heal
using natural remedies and then i
co-founded a company with jordan rubin
called ancient nutrition
that's the products i use right exactly
and with that like our
our motto is save the world with
superfoods and there's two things there
we want to save people and save the
planet
we truly believe that nutrition can help
save and transform lives and we also
believe we are called to be good
stewards to the planet and help heal the
planet
so we practice what's called
regenerative agriculture where we
plant superfood trees in fact we are
planting 10 million
superfood trees in 10 years to help
really heal the topsoil because one of
the things that's happened through
modern agriculture
we have totally depleted the soil in
fact the biblical principle is
rotate your crops it's let the land rest
every senior seven years we're not doing
that anymore we're
burning it through and cranking more
nitrogen into it that's starting over
right now that's exactly right yeah yeah
you know a lot there so again we're all
about
nutrient density of our foods and
teaching people how to use food as
medicine
okay so i want to go back to something
you you you touched on
that i struggle with okay i remember
sitting
at a campfire this is 20 years ago me
and some buddies went camping
and we were throwing cans into the fire
they were burning down
and i had brought a bag of twizzlers
and i threw one into the fire and i knew
the first thing this was wrong is it
burned
a different color than everything else
we were burning it burned blue it was
this weird bright blue thing yeah
but i remember waking up the next
morning and
you don't sleep good that first night of
camping out and all that cold
i walked by this fires all ash the cans
were all ash everything was burned
that twizzler was perfect it was red and
it was i remember thinking
that should not go in a human body and
then josh i kept eating them
how do at 14 you said i know this is bad
i know i shouldn't put this in my body
and you stopped
what is it the gap that people like me
struggle with
i know this but i just don't do that
yeah
you know what i mean yeah i think it's
not hard i know
yeah i think i think there's two things
i think you know it's
it's our perceived amount of pleasure
we're gonna get from something and then
also
the amount of pain we we we could avoid
by avoiding whatever that bad thing is
and so i think you know
and here's how i think about it too by
the way when i when i ran my clinic
i could tell immediately if somebody was
going to see good results or not based
on their perspective
because i'll give an example i would sit
down with somebody and i'd look at their
diet and it's like we're eating
processed cereal for breakfast and
you know processed milk and all these
things and i would say something to them
like okay
let me make a few recommendations here
before we get into our larger
recommendations
let's go and just start by changing
breakfast and i would say rather than
consuming what you're consuming now what
i'd like you to consume
is a superfood smoothie it's really
basic i'm gonna have you do like almond
milk or coconut milk
i'm gonna have you do some berries i'm
going to have you do some collagen
protein something like that
and i got two or two responses one
response was
wow that's amazing okay hey i'm all for
doing a berry smoothie
you know essentially like a strawberry
milkshake that's natural for breakfast
but then i had another group of people
that said oh
i can't have my you know my pancakes
every morning or i can't have the
and they sort of like they had this sort
of like they were gonna suffer mentality
so so the whole taking something from
them that was that's exactly right and
so i think if people just have the
perspective of
i'm not being somebody's not restricting
my life they're not taking it away from
me
versus wow this is a great new thing i'm
going to do i'm excited about it i'm
choosing to embrace it
i think it really all comes down to that
perspective in life is that hey
and also thinking about this what is
your why right i know you know we both
probably love simon sinek
and i love simon's thing start with why
and i think for us we're all called to
think about
what is our why and then after that
who's our who so
my my why is you know saving uh
families like like my mom you know and
uh and
and educating them on how to use food as
medicine and if i'm better fueled up and
if i'm eating right and if i live longer
it's going to help me do that
in that same way and then my family like
i'm doing it for my family i'm doing it
for god so i think when we think about
our why and our who
i also think that makes it easier we
talk a lot on this show like
my life goal is to be 93 and be able to
roll around the
floor with my grandkids i love it and
how do i reverse engineer that and that
that impacts how i lift and move and eat
and have a relationship
today right all of that works towards
that one goal
right which i love okay so
i we talk about mental health
relationships on this a lot
i've got a couple of what i don't know
what you call them
programs that take take research
articles from all over the country and
distill them down and send them to my
email box
once once a week the amount of stuff
coming out
is overwhelming right yeah and now it's
gotten to where
there's only a few an essay stuff i'm
talking to a fellow scientist so
the the research on nutrition on mental
health and this study and that study and
this
how do you stay on top of it because now
i've gotten to where i can't even stay
on top of
the people who stay on top of it right
they're coming out with new stuff all
the time
how do you wrap your head around or
maybe it's not maybe it's pretty simple
and it's there's a lot of drama a lot of
noise but the signals are staying the
same
that um i try to keep up with the stuff
so i stay right
so i know what's happening um how do you
do that
yeah so here's what i do and this is
what i love so much about what you do
and dave and friends of ours like ken
coleman is it's all about
principles there are principles that
stay the same
from the beginning of time till the end
of time and when you are anchored to
those core principles
you don't have to read every single
study out there you can read some and i
keep up on things but
it's not this it's not that's not my
anchor the the new research that comes
out today is not my anchor
these principles that are talked about
in places like the bible those are my
core principles that i live by and so
i'll give an example
you know this is there were studies that
have
came out many years ago and still not
recently to where
there were companies that were
pharmaceutical-based that owned
uh infant formula companies where they
started coming out with this research
saying
breast milk is not ideal for kids right
because it's high i'm not kidding no i
know they i know they are
yeah and so they started coming out with
these studies saying yeah breast milk is
not what's ideal for kids they're better
off with formula breast milk is not as
high in these certain vitamins and we
put these in there
but like we know that god created breast
milk to be the perfect
food for an infant and so
i'm just saying that to say this is that
we've got to understand a lot of these
big agricultural companies
pharmaceutical companies a lot of these
big
even financial institutions whatever it
is a lot of times there's the
there's agendas tied to them we're
talking about trillion dollar industries
here
so i think it's important to consider
that but for me you know i was on a
health panel with another
very prominent uh very prominent medical
doctor
and we were they were asked a question
exactly almost what you asked they said
hey with all the new research coming out
how do i decide what to eat and his
answer was
you decide based on whatever the
research just says
as of today so hey if it says today you
should be eating
apples eat apples if tomorrow says
apples are bad then stop eating apples
and i was literally my mind was blown
because i thought this is the way
literally a lot of people think about
this and for me it's like listen
bone broth has been consumed from the
beginning of time you know we have the
story in the
bible where you know jacob and esau are
like you know making soup
and you know we know that we've made
bone broth for a long time people have
consumed it they consume it in asia
today
in south america across the world it's
been a a
meal to help boost and support immune
health so all that being said number one
is i
anchor and understand these core
principles and then
i use this latest studies to
help educate and reinforce exactly what
uh how things work today so i've i've
noticed
i love that you said that i've noticed
an arc for the last 20 years
and about 10 years ago i was at a
at with a buddy and we're having dinner
and he was in the nutrition space and he
said hey
you know what's really freaking
everybody out on the front edge of all
this stuff
i said what he said that the data's
starting to come back pretty clear
if you eat whole foods and you have good
relationships and
you believe in something bigger than
yourself you're probably gonna be okay
most of the time oh yeah outside of an
acute
injury or some you know weird thing and
um that the arc of a lot of this
cutting edge banana research we're
spending bajillions of dollars on
fmri all these studies are leading us
back to
and slow down take care of your
relationships eat whole foods that's
right and take care of yourself
uh there's an old sam tele quote that
if it's not in nature if if you see
something in nature and you think you've
just figured out a new thing you're
probably wrong
yeah right and i love that um that that
sentiment
nature's had a long time to work on well
and i want to give example how wise some
of these
different sort of uh you know ancient
physicians were you know there was a
study that came out
about 10 years ago on turmeric
and if you consume the comp there's a
compounded tumor called curcumin right
which has all these anti-inflammatory
disease fighting benefits
and they found that when you consume it
with black pepper or piperine the
compound in it
it increased the absorption by 154
percent so the medical community like
sort of applauded themselves saying we
had this medical breakthrough we found
that when this happens here's the thing
there's a recipe in ayurveda
and this was also used in ancient asian
medicine and in middle eastern medicine
around the times of the bible
but there was an ancient recipe and it
was a blend of turmeric along with black
pepper ginger
and another warming spice and then gear
coconut it was
called turmeric golden milk or golden
tea that recipe has been around for
3 000 years where they knew that back
then
it's like so cheap exactly was it
hippocrates in a
in a jail cell talking about how health
begins in your gut
right that's right and it took us now
we're so excited about we discovered
that
that's right it's exciting right it's
awesome stuff all right so
i know the next question for the um some
of
our internet warriors will be these
specialized diets
the last hundred years especially last
25 years have turned into
these almost religious cult like
followings
you know what happened how did we get
here so these they are
wars man yes so so here's here's
essentially what's happened
and you'll get this john it's we have
number one here's here's the first thing
to realize
everyone is very unique individual i
mean god has made everybody unique in
their gifts and their skills even the
way their body works and functions
and ancient like asian medicine for
instance they put people in five types
so it's kind of like the enneagram
or disc profile or myers-briggs they
actually would say okay
you have certain emotions and your body
is built a certain way there are certain
foods that are better for creating
balance in your body in ancient times
they never treated a a labeled disease
they said
you've got this in balance where your
body's too hot or too cold internally
it's too damp or too dry
we've got to balance these things for
instance why do we call it a cold today
because with a cold it comes from
ancient asian medicine it's your body is
cold internally so you
people tend to take warming spices to
warm their body that's why it's always
like
oregano ginger cayenne these kind you
know like these
warming herbs and this little hot
toddies our grandparents used to
look so funny so here's the thing
whiskey and again we're not here
promoting everybody drink whiskey but
it's the hottest of all the cores it's
the most warming if anybody's ever had
they'll
warm your insides it's actually so it's
much better than something like a beer
which is cooling
all that being said so it's all about
bringing balance to the body to the
unique individual
so for some people keto diet is great
for probably about 20 25
of the population for a period of time
like maybe 30 days
okay but for a lot of people it's a
terrible diet
and what happens is somebody will say oh
i followed keto or i followed paleo or i
was a vegan
and it radically changed my health and
it's great for that person but i'd ask
everybody listening here
have you ever had a friend follow a diet
and it was not like a miracle for them
and then you tried the same thing it
didn't work for you exactly and that's
because
you're a unique individual and i'll give
you an example if somebody has
inflammatory bowel disease
they should not have they should have
zero raw vegetables it should all be
cooked vegetables bone broth like that
sort of thing but if somebody has liver
disease or cancer they do good with a
lot of raw foods and vegetable juices
so i mean really what you know ann
wigmore said
one man's food is another man's poison
and vice versa so it's important to
understand you're a unique individual
you really need to find what works for
you so unfortunately there's nothing
but but yes there have become these
cult-like followings of certain diets
and and to their uh you know
it has worked for them but it definitely
doesn't work for everybody
and we've talked about this on this show
is if we step back 100 200 years we've
had this
cultural obsession with shoving
everything into a bell curve that's
right what's the thing that works for
everybody
and because we can sell it to everybody
yup and so we stamped this imaginary
um food pyramid this is how we should
all do it doesn't work
right and it's it can feel untethering
to think
oh gosh then what is the thing and
that's where you get
walk alongside a good practitioner and
you learn to listen to your body and
this works and this doesn't and
and then now i mean my wife she's she's
one that can handle
high high carbohydrate intake yeah i'm
so jealous
and i'm somebody who can handle very
little and we both meet no
and we figured out how to have great
family meals and she doesn't get her
feelings hurt i don't get my feelings
our kids so it's it's in the middle
there
how do you you've been in this space a
long time how do you deal with
um people come after you right there's a
lot of chris
and it's not criticism like hey we don't
we disagree with you the criticism is
you're hurting people
like you're crazy what are you doing
right how do you deal with that man
yeah so you know for me and what's funny
is i i don't i don't read a lot of those
comments now i want to be aware i want
to be responsible
but for me i just i anchor into these
core principles and a lot of them start
in the bible these health
biblical principles and then they really
go off as well to
you know these ancient things that i
think have been proven for again as i
mentioned
thousands of years now and then in
running a practice myself so
for me i guess i combat it with this
i'll give an example if somebody would
say
dr axe when you speak out or or tell
people that
their first line of defense should be
nutrition and mindset and relationships
and all of those sort of these lifestyle
factors
and people should focus on those even
before they would go and take
pop a pill hey that that's that's
hurting people we really believe that
today's medical system is the way that
things should be done and so
i've heard that plenty but anybody says
that anymore but
i know i got you i literally had
somebody the other day
stop me and say you're hurting people
with all your false information out
there just a random person on the street
awesome but then i'm at whole foods and
i have all my old patients coming up to
me and stopping and saying oh dr axe
like hey i actually had a woman come up
pretty recently and she
she had lost 80 pounds her husband had
lost 120 pounds
and he was a former nfl offensive
lineman so i mean he just
you know he he he lost way to transform
himself so i have so many thousands of
people that have shared with me
their their health transformation
reversing diabetes
overcoming hypothyroidism fertility you
know so many women who now have been
able to have kids following some of this
information
so so for me i really just fill up on
those things and you're gonna have
haters you're gonna have doubters
but at this point i don't know i've got
pretty thick i've got pretty thick skin
i think if you just focus on those
things and focus on your mission and
vision
that really helps too because for me
saving people saving the world with
super food knowing i've got to
you know i want to help heal the planet
i want to help people and knowing all
these positive results we've seen
kind of it kind of is like a i don't
know it's more like i have a nat around
me now it doesn't really
didn't get you yeah so i'm going to
speak my life into yours and you may say
that i don't have that at all
i'm similar there and for a season man
it i wouldn't sleep at night like
someone would write something mean
especially when i was working with with
college students or with police officers
i was i was doing stuff after hour and
say hey
terribly and man that would wipe me out
now i've
i've got people that i can call if i get
stuck and
um i'm i'm more like you my skin's got a
lot thicker
my wife's hasn't right and so when
someone's ugly with me she's ready to go
to war oh man and so
you're married um how do you manage that
that like the most important
relationship to you
and she i don't know she has a tendency
to go to war on your behalf but
how do you how do you manage that
criticism being counter cultural
saying hey i'm cool but also man you
love this person who really loves you
yeah you may say she doesn't do that at
all but no she does see i'm that's why
i'm laughing so
my my wife is uh and let me see my
wife's also a physician okay so she went
to chiropractic college she got training
and like functional
uh uh nutrition and an exercise and
she's a yoga instructor so she has a lot
of credentials herself
and she's just an amazing strong
christian principled woman
and so for that she's there but she is
my biggest defender
okay and if you want to get her fired up
it's you know
come after me or our family and so there
are occasions where i'm like
hey we're good yeah we're good hey just
you know
um but but yeah i mean she's definitely
my biggest offender and that's i mean
what a blessing you know to be an
embarrassed
and i know you feel the same way it's
like maybe when you have a spouse who is
for you yeah you know like that it's uh
but but it absolutely bothers her more
than it bothers me absolutely and i
think it'd be the same thing if somebody
if somebody says something negative
about chelsea
my wife oh dude it's on i'm definitely
again it's
10x how i feel about it somebody says
about me okay so flip that around
another thing that i just imagined too i
was joking around this i one of
two of our best friends they have a
daughter we have a one-year-old they
have a one and a half year old
and we're joking around the other day so
like our daughter now she's waving to
people
and like if somebody doesn't wave back
actually i get i'm like
guy like you know anyways
it's a whole nother level
yeah if they somebody rolls their eyes
at them at a restaurant
it's like dude we can go in the parking
lot it's for no reason right yeah
and my kids being annoying too by the
way um but yeah i'm the same way
so let's flip that around a little bit
um
i think one of the challenges i've
experienced
is we have a bunch of credentialed
people speaking into the world
with a lot of different platforms and a
lot of different motivations
one is i really i saw my mom suffer and
i don't want anyone to do that i'm gonna
go down a rabbit hole to figure out what
happened
and then oh my gosh i've got my own
patience i want to help heal the planet
and this stuff's all interconnected
whatever that looks like yep
then you get other folks who just want
to sell a book or just want to make some
money et cetera
one of the biggest challenges i'm
looking at seeing is
people's inability to say hey i
really really believed in that i was
wrong
and one of the cool so i was an academic
nerd before i came here
and i saw um i saw it happen with covet
in a pretty unique way
i knew from my researcher friends that
when somebody lays down
a hey we think 11 million people are
gonna die in
in the for scientists their job is to be
less wrong
and so they immediately go cool we're on
and so
then a few weeks later another group
another college group says hey
only six million are going to die hey we
got a new model we'll put it on this
and the whole art of science is being
less wrong then the two
groups that can't say that word are
politicians and media people
and if a scientist has rolled himself up
into a media world then they get locked
into
i can't say i was wrong on something one
of the first people to tell me i'm wrong
is often my wife is a
is a phd researcher too it's her to say
john you
are way off on what are you talking
about have you had something that you
were dead set on and suddenly you've
been like
oh i wasn't right on that i've even had
to come on this show
i've called somebody back and said i
gave you wrong advice man i should have
told you something else
you know so so i'll share a couple
things early on in my career
i really felt like the more plants the
better in terms of raw
and i was sharing that earlier and i had
to learn through clinical experiences
that
a raw like like for instance a salad
most people think a salad is good for
everybody so even my clinic first year i
taught some raw food classes and all
these things and then i was
started working with people with crohn's
and ulcerative colitis and ibs
and started noticing wow this is not
working for these people diverticulitis
some others
and and i had to go learn you know and
so i was
that that's just an example of my
nutritional philosophy
being wrong and that really led me to
really continuing to study more of
of what i study now and there there's
been you know
i almost always listen to chelsea but i
mean
anytime i don't listen to my wife i'm it
is wrong i mean i can tell you it's like
10 out of 10. 10 out of 10. it's 100 out
of 100 for me there you go
hey before you skip over this listen i
know that sometimes we try to sell you
stuff on here during these breaks but
today i'm gonna flip that around and
give you an opportunity to win
cash not really cash amazon gift cards
but same thing right
listen we're the most surveyed group of
people
ever in the history of the world and i'm
beat down by surveys just like you right
you go to a drive-through and you just
want to get a burger and fries
and some weird diseases all on your own
and then by the time you drive through
they're texting you
hey will you answer five questions about
no no i just want my burger right
i get that surveys are super lame
so here i come at you with a survey but
here's the deal here's the deal
this show has always been for you about
you and you are
critical to what we're doing here right
so we're doing our very first listener
survey for this show
please don't roll your eyes i know i
know i know but listen i want to hear
what you enjoy
what you don't enjoy i want to hear what
you want to hear more of in each episode
do you want more interviews more callers
any specialized topics teaching segments
plus we got to get to the bottom of
whether we need more horse noises or not
right what guitar is the best
all that stuff i want to hear from you
right so text the word survey to 33789
to take the survey
and i'll enter you in a chance to win a
50 amazon gift card
that's survey s-u-r-v-e-y to-33789 just
text that
and it closes on friday july 9th so do
it today
i want to hear from you
yeah who who else do you have in your
life
in my research with high performing
folks and folks who are whose job is to
take care of their people
that number one across the board when
they get themselves in trouble
whether it's psychologically spiritually
mentally whatever
it's because they stop listening to a
close group of people
mentors friends
to all of them my biggest life lesson is
you become who you surround yourself
with
and so i am so conscious of community in
fact when i uh
before i married chelsea i knew how
important a spouse was and so i prayed
to god i said god would you send me a
wife who is
mentally stimulating physically
breathtaking and spiritually just on
fire for you so like i was so conscious
of like
knowing the person i'm going to spend
the most time with i i wanted to be a
woman who wanted to be a world changer
and just a great mom and a great what
and god brought that person along for me
so that's one number one is chelsea
number two
is my business partner one of my best
friends jordan rubin so jordan rubin he
founded a company many years ago called
garden of life sold that and now we
co-founded
ancient nutrition he wrote a book called
the maker's diet so jordan
jordan is about six years older than me
and um and so like even when i was
authoring my first book
uh nancy alcorn who i know yeah uh we
know who runs mercy multiplied in
ministry here i met him through that
ministry
and he gave me some really great life
advice on
publishing a book and starting and
growing a business and all those
different things
so those are two of the biggest ones and
i've got a mastermind or a men's
leadership group i'm a part of
got guys like colt morton dan sullivan
andrew east dave tughel and some others
that i
i'm just very deeply connected to but i
would say from a mentorship standpoint
um jordan he's a at this point he's one
of my best friends but he's still
again there's been a lot of mentorship
he's given me over the years
awesome and i have some other pastors as
well you have john bevere
uh you know is a friend and uh and
and uh quite a few other pastors that we
look to we actually
for our business we have a our our board
of directors that's out of california
but then we also have what we call our
it's called our kingdom council we have
a spiritual board
where we have nine pastors sit on our
board we do quarterly meetings with them
they speak both into our life and
business
so anyways yeah i'm glad you asked
because that it is a huge huge part of
my life and making sure that i have
other people
you know hold me accountable that that's
awesome
do you ever have challenges mixing
spirituality
and business yes you know our our board
of first off we have we are super
blessed we have a board of directors
that is incredible
and their values are you know some align
some might be a little bit different
than ours
so i think in the areas of few areas
where they're not completely
you know we might feel a little
different i think that's a challenge and
the spiritual
board we have is is very much like
listen just do what's right in the eyes
of god completely
and the other board is a little bit more
let's toe the line and just be
safe and so i think that you know for
the most part
um you know we there have been
challenges but i think for us
we we have um navigated them with the
best
you know you know wisdom we could and so
i don't know i don't know if i have a
great answer there i'll just say but
yeah there
there are yeah i mean there are
challenges as a business because
myself and jordan both have very very
strong faith-based
based values and there are marketing
campaigns people want you to do certain
times and months of the year and other
things and we decide that hey
you know what the marketing campaign the
sort of injustice those sort of things
we're going to fight
we're going to do things our way the way
we feel biblically i'll give you an
example of this and
i hope this is okay to talk about you
know we had uh when um
you know earlier uh in the year we had
there's a
black lives matter and i think a lot of
people wanted us to go and like we were
getting
messages pounding us daily go and
support this organization
and we said you know what number one
give us a day to pray and talk it
through with with our
with with with jordan and i and our
company president and we said you know
what like we want to be about
fighting social justice we want to be
about doing good in the world and
transforming lives
here's what we're going to do we're
going to go and we're going to start a
scholarship and and
fund children the african-american
community
getting a better education fight you
know do these initiatives we're going to
change the way we hire so we made all of
these changes
we got criticism maybe because we didn't
have a certain post
on instagram but we said we want to be
the sort of people
that are fighting and so i'm just giving
an example
we are very conscious of like we want to
be a light to the world we want to have
an
impact but we want to do it in the way
that jesus would have done it
that's transformative exactly not the
way that because here's what most people
do today they're like we just want to
look good we're not going to actually do
anything
but we want to look good and that's what
you see when you see all these
celebrities and these people
out there talking about certain things
they're doing almost
nothing gotcha and so i just you know we
want to be the change
and and let let that change be
represented and
like your company will look different
right and your neighborhoods will look
different and the people you come in
contact look different right right
that's that's fantastic man so when it
comes to food
movement healthy living i'm gonna ask
you a trick question first and then
we'll get to the real
what is something that would surprise
people
that you are militant about with your
new child
and what would surprise somebody that
you're a lot more lacks with your kid
sure a couple things one um
you know we uh so i used to be under the
impression this is another example where
i'm wrong
where i've been wrong that everything i
eat should be perfect
like i and before i met chelsea she
would tell you she softened me up a
little bit
you know trips to italy and that sort of
thing helped too where it's like hey i'm
in tuscany it's like i can't not
yeah pizza and gelato right now but so
that being said
like we actually give her foods that uh
we know she's gonna be exposed to
we we give her as she's growing we give
her a little bit of gluten we give her
some dairy we give her
certain products that if she was doing
in large amounts she may have a
uh reaction or an intolerance too but
that we know like
we our bodies are created we actually
should strengthen our bodies through
getting these micro exposures stress
responses
yeah yeah yeah yeah and so we actually
really do that with arwen to where we're
giving her certain things
uh in small doses to naturally help
support and strengthen her immune system
so that's one thing we we absolutely do
um
so that's that's you at a restaurant and
there's a some like i don't know i'm
just making something up but uh
it's when people come by and see my
daughter eating a
piece of like a cheese pizza it's a
and nobody's got it yeah i think yeah
and here's the other thing i found when
you go to a place like italy and some of
the areas of the world that have the
longest lifespan even japan
that they're not eating perfect there's
the biggest thing
is actually low stress and healthy
relationships
they're not psychotic about it yeah now
they move but they're not actually
they're not lifting weights they're
riding bicycles they're walking they're
sweating
they're gardening they're doing those
things and they're eating very clean but
then they're
once or twice a week they're having a
vacation meal they're having a couple
glasses of wine they're having you know
a little too much you know sugar on
occasion but it's not every day it's
just sort of sprinkled
in it's not you know you know it's it's
not the dominant part of the way they
eat
gotcha so
probably the most annoying question any
nutrition any person who goes down the
rabbit hole of nutrition is because we
talked about this earlier is
okay then what give me the five things i
need to be eating sure like
in every guy i've ever met or or man or
woman who's a
researcher who said we'll say well it
depends right that's the commentary
what is what is a couple of things that
if you're watching this or listening to
this
if i just did this and stopped that
that's relatively universal
what would you recommend to somebody off
the top yeah i mean it's
it's two things you eat a lot more
vegetables a lot less sugar and
carbohydrates i mean
and i know that's what everyone's going
to hear but that's awesome though but
that's
hands down everybody almost yeah i'm
actually thinking one guy who doesn't
but
i almost think about everybody who
pretty much agrees with this
that the one person i was going to bring
up there's actually a uh
someone i had on my podcast recently who
promotes a nose-to-tail diet which
essentially is eating
almost all meat oh is that sedan yeah
exactly
it's a salad oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so
he actually just emailed me this morning
about something yeah um
but that being said uh but listen
i look at his body type and based on
what i know about some
things like chinese medicine i know when
i look at him i'm like yeah your body
types can do very well with that diet
that's an example
i look at him i hear him and in chinese
medicine it's known as the
fire element which essentially means
somebody would do well in like a keto
diet that sort of body type in person
they do well with spicy foods and those
sort like so yeah he'll do well with
that
diet um anyways but i and
so here's a few other things i think
generally speaking from a diet
standpoint
my number one recommendation is this
just change breakfast
even if you don't change lunch and
dinner if you just change breakfast
that's one third of your diet that's
actually a pretty
pretty big change do something like a
superfood smoothie it's very easy three
ingredients
coconut or almond milk a cup of fruit
like berries
and like vanilla collagen or vanilla
bone broth powder something
like that for breakfast if you do that
that's a huge change
and then just try and focus on getting a
vegetable with lunch and dinner
and i think if you do that that's going
to go a long long way and i wrote a book
pretty recently too it's called ancient
remedies
and i go through where people can find
out their ideal sort of diet type so
there's five main diet types throughout
history
that have been most effective for people
so people can take a quiz and learn
hey i need a diet that's more for my
immune system or one more for my
hormones or one for detoxification
system or for brain
and sort of go through that in that book
um
and it's that sort of form of
personalized diet but i would say that
that's
i would say yeah changing your breakfast
trying to load up and get a lot more
vegetables
uh is probably the thing that's going to
go the furthest
so you sparked one more question i gotta
ask yeah let's go
how do you this is a this is a global
issue right now
let's take paul for instance he's for
those who don't know is very outspoken
on the carnivore diet strong personality
has an awesome book he wants to sell
but also is a physician also lives it
right i think most of his podcasts are
done with no shirt on right
you've got friends you and i both have
friends all over the spectrum i've got
friends who are psychiatrists
who i will go have dinner and i'll just
say you are destroying earth and they'll
say you're an idiot right
how do you stay in relationship with
folks who have
same credentials all both also see
patients
and see the world a little bit
differently how do you how do you stay
in a relationship with folks like that
how do you stay in community with people
like that
yeah so for me it's this way one i know
what i'm called to do like i i think
this helps a lot i think when you know
uh you're wise big you're responsible
for this
but not for this yep then that helps so
for me i know i'm responsible for three
big things
loving god which is essentially means
for i just want to clarify for me that
means
having an intimate relationship with him
i know he hears me i know
how how uh just what a good dad he is
and and also loving somebody i know his
dreams i know his desires i know what he
wants me to do i'm being obedient i'm
having this
i'm being trustworthy with him so i'm
building a deep interrelation with him
so i'm loving god
loving people and i'm trying to make
earth a heavenly place those are the
three things i believe i've called to do
gotcha and so with that loving people
means it's not
me you know forcing them to do anything
it's not me
trying to push my political opinion on
them or my diet
health opinion or anything else it's
seeing them where they're at
and trying to you know there's a great
book by tim keller i love it's the
meaning of marriage
and our job as spouses is to make each
other holy and you don't do that by
forcing it you do that by
living a life yourself you do that by
encouraging people you do that by
finding the greatness in them and
supporting and calling out and saying
doing a combination of i call it this is
i believe what
leadership is it's nourishing somebody
loving somebody and then challenging
them holding them to
ins and showing them what they're
capable of and the ultimate thing that
god's called them to do
in that order right exactly which i love
yeah and so and so what i try and do if
i'm in that sort of relationship it's
hey paul man i love that you're doing
this i love you doing this by the way i
saw this interview man you were so well
like i'm encouraging them and i'm and
this isn't inauthentic
and so i'm pulling out what you are
great at and also but you know what
i really think you should consider
looking into this because i think this
is a little off
i had this personal experience where i
saw this
but hey just want to let you know still
hey i love you i just i love what you're
up to
so you know what i'm saying it's just
sort of like and it's also a love
sandwich there too so
yeah but that's so so i think too and
because
we're in a difficult world today with
the heated political tension where it's
really
easy for me to see somebody and think
it's easy for me to become resentful
really easy for i think most people too
today especially when we're talking
politics in these different things
but i think i got to realize they're
they're not called and i'm not called to
make people believe like
like i i believe i'm called to just
nourish and challenge them serve other
people yeah
yeah i have come to love
having a collection of friends who are
also experts
who i disagree with i i've come to just
love that
um because if i just circle surround
myself with the same books
that i've read the same five times and
the same
perspectives i know one thing i know
i'm just gonna sit where i'm at right
and there'll be no
there'll be no growth there'll be no
movement that we know anything and i
end up just sitting still right and it
becomes i've just become a boring lazy
person
and so i i've come to love that and what
i'm trying to do is to get outside my
head and say
is there a secret sauce to that am i
just built weird because i love
disagreeing with people in
in lovely fun ways over meals i'd never
i just don't understand fighting
but i do love healthy discussion
and i just makes my my life more rich
but i love to hear that from you too
well i love this because there's a book
and uh a person who actually mentioned
me years ago his name was skip moen and
he has his phd in hebrew and not just
hebrew it's the hebrew
of genesis and so he wrote a book and
it's really good it really goes through
the hebrew perspective
of christianity and the war in a world
view it's a little book about world view
and he really looks and he said listen
the western world view is all about
black and white
we're going to debate and essentially
you're my enemy here in western world
view what was brought up by the greeks
and especially the romans
and sort of this thing where it's like
you're right or wrong everything is
black and white in that way
versus the eastern viewpoint and really
more of jesus viewpoint or what practice
even in the east today is
now hey listen we're gonna have a
conversation today we don't have to
completely agree with each other
we're called to love and support each
other but we we can have a
disagreement and and argue and that's
normal in fact
you know when you read up in the new
testament read all about rabbis rabbis
were constantly
that's the part of the joy right that's
right yeah and it was over meals as
you're saying and so i think i think
remembering that it's not about being
today it's all about are you right or
are you wrong
who wins and losses right yeah and and
today
it's it's like nobody we've all heard
this quote you've probably said it on
your show
nobody wins an argument right and so i
think keeping that in mind that it's not
about winning or losing it's about
uh you know loving god loving people
making earth a heavenly place what
what can you do to help do that and
that's what and even in business right
now like we're so conscious of that
healing the planet helping heal people
um you know i think uh again
those are the things i think that i just
constantly try and keep top of mind love
it dude
all right real quick what do you got
going on that we can direct people to
so yeah i got a new book out it's called
ancient remedies um and it actually
already has over a thousand reviews
people can find that on amazon.com if
they just search ancient remedies dr
axe uh my company ancient nutrition uh
we uh you know we create collagen and
probiotics all these products people can
find them in health food stores or
online you can just search
you know ancient nutrition dr axe all of
our products and
and then yeah those are probably the
biggest biggest things and i'll tell
people i took today
the vanilla bone broth um
powdered vanilla bone broth yep and i
put it in my coffee and just let it
dissolve in there and it was awesome
and i also took your sea and the zinc
probiotic so
nice work i i love the working strong
immune system look at that i hope so
i got young kids and i live out in the
woods i think
we eat enough dirt in my house that yeah
we're good um
so we end up every show with the
greatest song of all time and
i speak mostly in hyperbole and so i've
got about 10 000 favorite songs and
movies
and so i asked every guest who's on the
show
if you had to just distill it down into
the one song that makes you cry when
you're driving
or that you sing along with and start
chanting out loud whether it's the old
bon jovi song or something whatever
what's the song what's the one that
moves your soul wow well i feel like for
me you know
uh music is always sort of changing um
uh so i i have a song i love right now
it's called joyful by dante beau
and so it's just it's a great song most
people haven't heard of me they should
check it out joyful dante bow
i think you'll like it joyful by dante
beau spell
his name uh b-o-w-e
well dude thanks for being with me hey
john thanks so much around thank you so
much
hey we'll be right back
hey i hope you liked the interview with
dr josh axe if you're interested in any
of his products
getting his books we've linked to them
in the show notes
and if you just fast forwarded through
the whole interview here it is in a
nutshell
eat less carbs put the doughnut down
drink more whiskey this has been the dr
john dolone's show